um
all right beaver yeah fever uh tell me
uh tell me where you grew up where are
you from originally
uh howard county kentucky harlan county
and new york and
tell me uh tell me about your childhood
you had both your parents when you were
a kid above my parents yeah
what kind of childhood do you have well
i my family have eight i had twelve
i was like younger and i had a lot of
hand me down but
i had a predictive yeah this is a poor
part of the country and
your family was probably poor my dad had
to go out of work he worked out of state
what'd your dad do ain't cockney work
carpenter built people
go tell him and i was mom my mom you
halfway
you know you know she raised the garden
tell us what what we know what we really
know
mom that they gone die they did a week
you know one weekend now he takes gunk
all weekend
then you you have tomorrow what age 13
13 at home
what kind of kid were you uh hard to
hard handle
oh man he want me all the time and
i didn't come up higher i'd leave i just
mounted my mom wake me up
so you left home at three at 13 yeah and
it went up to
where i was slept in barn and people got
these buildings
basically smoke out and you finished
high school did you go to high school
uh i went about about a year in high
school yeah
and and then they're asking me
i would want something something
something bigger something better what
kind of things have you done for work
in your life well caught me built a
couple houses
like you know like like black and brick
rock
caught
right and you make moonshine yes
tell me about uh tell me about moonshine
how do you make moonshine well you gotta
make beer first
you gotta put my monster's mountain corn
then i don't want it much sprouts you
gotta ground it up
and then put it in and boil water
then you add water and you have the
yeast then you your meal and then you
add your sugar
more sugar you make more liquor you got
so you
you got a fish background drum you put
down sugar
then you wait germinate and
you taste it every couple days and it's
underneath the beer
then you put it in a steel then you then
you run it build a cup of wine then
you've got a pumpkin
and then it runs you run your you want
them in a coat with cold water
and once that sting hits that cold water
it just turns in alcohol and turned in
and just dropped it in a jug in a jar it
ends up clear as
water right water yeah what is there's a
bottle of it right in front of you what
does moonshine like it's is it
like vodka is it like well it's got it
it's got its own taste
it's harder than whiskey or vodka right
now i have a bourbon yeah
anything else comes out of steel about
140 fruit
140 proof then you got that clear good
good clear water
tamper it down to where you want 80
proof or 90 100
and how do you drink it you don't drink
it right yeah you slip on it
you just put your lips to it really yeah
you don't quit you don't quit
the moonshot is popular here in this
part of the country
yeah a lot of people we've talked to
said can you get me any moonshine and
yeah tell them i'm going to talk to you
and they said yeah get me some
it's been a brilliant fan yeah how could
people you
can find it it's illegal yeah yeah
what are what are the penalties like for
making moonshine which uh
dale has federal fans tough federal fans
yeah you got to have a steal but you
can't have it
put together
what's the purpose of having a a drink
that's so strong
well they say stronger the better yeah i
mean it won't
kill all the worms in you you know
except keep liquor
you know rock guts right yeah i heard
you
only know how you don't understand yeah
your dad used to drink it yeah you know
all the time man you're working
yeah and tell me about your life so you
you have uh you got married at one point
yeah at my 90. went together 20 some
years before we got before she died you
got 21 years already
died to cancer tonight and then 2011.
and you have uh you have a daughter have
one daughter yeah she born in 2014.
since you're in the woman died yeah
yeah if you ever got me over here and
then then
this during that one week would come
true i always wish i had a young boy
died yeah i raised three yep young and
you know
the boy her boy was well you know when
we got together
now you know i walked both my girls down
the aisle the real dad did it was still
living but
that's the only time i wore trucks in my
life i i'm doing yeah
tell me about living in appalachia it's
it's a one of the poorest parts of the
country
it's hard it's hard to get a dollar you
know it's hard to make money here
there's two jobs and if you've got
garden worker
you know uh odd jobs for people and coal
mining which used to be the only option
yeah i never could i didn't like coal
mining
yeah because it's dangerous or logging i
didn't like login called
dangers yeah yeah
do you consider yourself a hillbilly yes
100. tell me about
what is the hillbilly is it a derogatory
term is it a negative term
well you still believe this morning and
raising you raised on the land and you
live off the land you want to you're
proud of being a hilltop i'm proud of it
yeah
i'm taking nothing out what is a
hillbilly tell me
what's your definition of hillbilly uh
live on your own
live land you know don't take pride in
everything you do
and you know that's about it it's almost
like an outlaw
yeah out for this part of the country at
london wow yeah
but i think you're in guild town heavy
yeah what kind of stuff got you in jail
drugs drugs you used to use dorks yeah i
need guns yeah you still do
i have one for a while but what would
have what have you played with in the
past
cocaine iron two times maybe one and i
just wanted once in a while i think the
first time i photographed you you had a
whole field of marijuana
yeah yeah yeah that's 12 years ago
yeah and uh living here i mean
what are the upsides and downsides of
appalachia i mean the doctors and
dentists are very few and far between
right
yeah the car it's hard to try to pay
bills you have no income
you know i don't it's right now though
but right because my health
how do you know i'm 58 58. yeah
can you have you traveled have you been
in other parts of the country yeah i've
been in chicago
florida georgia you know
places like that i didn't then they'd
like to laugh i stayed in chicago five
years but
i worked up for everybody yeah make big
money and spend big money
yeah man no place like home this this is
one of the most beautiful parts of the
country yeah yeah
it might be one of the poorest and
toughest to survive but yeah it is
spectacularly beautiful
yes it is are you happy i'm happy here
yeah natural land
yeah you always seem to be i
photographed you from my first book and
you seemed to be
yeah yeah yeah you know truly loving
this life yeah
what are your best memories in your life
um
best memories i guess been my family
been have family unions
yeah they don't have that no more and
then we didn't get together now
they're all spot-on spots all the time
and once they're like some you know
one of us
tell me more about epiphalesia there's
there's there's hunting here there's a
lot of animals right yeah a lot of
animals
you know bear hunt fire turkey
deer yeah you know but my one was you
wouldn't thinking nothing like that you
know she wrote and everything about a
story
i went to that next 180 you know
me i need anything you know like that
but he wasn't like that he
went from the store she wouldn't need it
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life be honest
be honest be honest about it honestly
this policy
i don't think the hard way you know i
stole stuff in my life but
it don't pay it don't know does not pay
honestly the best policy it's hard to do
around this neighborhood you know
it feels good it'll probably get a lick
up though
it does and i've done it 20 years you
know i
had no retirement but you know i had
some kind of living yeah i didn't
nothing to brag about
what uh what regrets do you have in your
life pardon do you have any regrets
yeah a whole lot of rats i still like my
family
you know missing that you know i've ever
grown up live
took me 40 years from me i you know what
was wrong with my
i think i'm back here by myself but off
that way i guess you know
i worry about nobody else bother me i
mean by nobody else
how is your personality different than
everyone else in your family
well uh i'm the
last boy was born and got three fingers
i guess
and just i just bought like a bunch i
mean i don't wanna never had a public
job
i always survive on my own pick up pops
in about make bottles for living you
know
just out just try to live up you know
health land
and you know my head like that's all i
got you know before i got here
everything's mine right here
you know i've got some people give come
in i've got garbage dumps and this and
that
so you live up on top of a mountaintop
all by yourself here
yeah i don't think the cops could even
find you if they wanted to uh they
they've been here over time
yeah they've been here they've been here
everyone in this town knows you
yeah they go i don't know but they know
me
yeah a lot of people know me don't know
them
in different states yeah
what are you uh famous for
uh growing probably yes moonshine
yeah so tell me about your life you
you still have hope for things in your
life or i see my girl
see my girl's 18th birthday that's the
only thing i hope for in
life now you know she that's 11 more
years i don't know if i might get that
more year or not
but i'm quitting my ways you know
he was should be seven in may yeah i
said to you
when she was born
did you have friends here yeah i got all
kinds of friends yeah the so-called
friend you know
when you're down and out and that's when
you know your friends are in jail one
tell me about uh tell me about your hand
what happened to your hand well that
fella right there
ever caught well with chopping wood in
74.
kenneth my old man played cardio all
night coming i want to build a flower
and we was outside and at about one
o'clock in the morning
and we got outside shopping kindling on
a big old chop block and i laid
a piece of wood about six inches around
the cop cannon he was coming down the
axe and hit cut slamming the chains on i
got him set back up
that's when he come down and i can cut
it off because i didn't i hear about
hiking too
and i laid it up like that shut my hand
together i got it packed out
and i know where i was in the hospital
so show me your hand you're missing
my little pinky and i remember
i had pictures in wintertime and i took
these sweatshirts on and
i remember cutting up on my arm and then
digging in on my arm jumping myself
putting blood everywhere how long does
it take to get to a hospital here
about two hours i had to give me three
pounds of blood it happened to be on the
other side
where the people were taking what what
my where i lost my finger at right
but maybe these days they could put it
back on but back seven before i didn't
yeah and then he was your friend and he
remained your friend after removing your
finger
he's my brother-in-law yeah yeah and
there's my sister yeah
and he was actually you know he you know
he felt really a long time but you know
do you ever wonder what your life would
have been like if you'd been born in new
york city
or oh i've been pitiful i've been david
now
probably i'd say you know well i've been
you know it's time to
you know i i've had a good life where i
looked at it you know
and then when they were hogging they
were bleeding you know i would take a
small amount when i'm about my business
i never feel like that i didn't need
you know i had to be honest with you i
mean i i really don't court system i
always told the truth
like my mom i would tell them so what do
you do for
enjoyment at this point in your life
what makes you happy
well i've always had these i got a
dollar in my pocket or
a joint i'm happy i'm here i got
something to eat and my dog's younger
ain't hungry
you know how to ask nobody enough you
know i do that before i have to ask
somebody
that's always been that way we gotta get
on home and i'll do that
that's why we've been that way
when you were a kid did you have dreams
of doing something in life yeah what
kind of stuff
make up being a cop yeah you ended up
the opposite of that yeah
yeah i could make better when i was 12
grand there from breaking entry
but i stopped that night
yeah i was 18 years old before i got
grade school
i don't want to start the secretary and
going to school about 18 so i got a
great
grade school quite i got graduate
to go back to school uh yeah i went to
eat though so you know
play while i was in the family you know
it's hard to raise enough garden you
know
we'd like 200 pound taters and i'd work
in the garden all the time come on
scream i had to go to work and and if
that isn't working out hard enough
he made him take like a rock pile like a
rock problem here and move it over if i
didn't like it but i didn't really
quickly make me back
that's what mine was he mean to it all
those
he was you know he he typed on me i
think my dad
you know he means my mom you know
that's life i guess
everybody in this county knows of you
you uh
you don't follow the rules you you seem
to be like this
outlaw legend that lives up on this
mountain all by himself
you've lived a life that a lot of us
fantasize about
uh crazy life i mean i love hammy dan i
mean
any runs runs with the law oh yeah i got
away with i i've been
nine some families and no conviction
that's what i'm getting in my five years
nine something nine some charges but no
conviction no
97 yeah i tried yeah failing charges no
conviction
and i finally you know we don't go back
history you won't get your time
so i pulled 28 months straight so i got
out
and i got a couple years sentence and
then that's when i turned over 40 that's
admittedly they made for me
that's when the tank going straight it's
still hard it's hard to go straight
but it pays you the long run you sleep
better than that
you sleep at night yeah that's right and
then you go you get honest
i already asked people you know they
didn't have that give it to you you know
when they didn't work for it
you know like my mom always said
but what are you what are you proud of
in your life well
i guess when i got my girl was born most
powerful
been in my life my girl was born but she
was born in jail
i didn't know she was mine that was 18
months old
but like one week come true are you a
religious person
yeah i believe in baptism yeah i believe
in god yeah
you ever set foot in a church a church
before yes yes
yeah several times yeah but i just
didn't like the preacher
you know he kind of gave me that
you know everybody you know hey maybe he
will in turkey just as much as you are
out here
but you can't go with that you just kind
of you know don't believe your own
belief
what do you think of the future of uh of
life here in appalachia for people i
mean it seems like this lifestyle is
kind of fading away
it's getting worse it's getting rougher
if you if you don't you can't lay the
garden it's gonna be rough on you
another five years down the road your
story's gonna go out of business it
can't be enough land you you've had a
hard time
you're gonna be hard it's gonna be rough
on you yeah you're the last of a breed i
think
that yeah yeah so enough
i reckon these animals make a living on
anything anthony 22.
give me a year i can i can live two or
three on it i'm a guardian
is that right okay good you know
it seems like drugs are taking over the
community here
it is it is it's gotten really bad in
the last 20 years right yeah you have a
logging close friendly
maybe that crank and crystal mess
heroin now taking over
10 years ago you know something heroin
the was
maybe a few fields marijuana night they
were
but they they doped the other they they
met the others they
do to one of them was the worst part of
your life losing your wife what was the
worst time of your life
losing your wife uh i leave my wife yeah
mom and dad
well that's my dad my mom took at 94
like my dad took out 15. who are you
closer to mom
well i closed my mom yeah that i always
stayed away all the time
yeah you ever get depressed here
yeah man then yeah they don't you know
you're lying to you yeah yeah you're
depressed yeah
yeah but now they're never alone you
know somebody's always heard my dog make
me company somebody's always here yeah
every time i've been here
i've been here several times and you've
always had people hanging out some
people live outside of me too my family
lived inside of me
well i lived up here in my family i know
outsiders lived here
it's my family it's family it's probably
it's probably been my family since 1800
early 1800s
your whole family has lived in uh in
norman county
are you born in this old house down here
on the hill here
and he he morning 27 and assuming he's
still standing there how many
generations have you guys been here you
think
uh five six my great great grandpa
patented patented probably in 1929.
and it's been my it's been it's probably
been in my family ever since
my dad my brother just lived here
another
was born overnight over there somewhere
here
and they got the house got burnt doing
you know how what do you what
do you ever hear of what your
grandfather's great great grandparents
uh
did for for money well they made
moonshine and then moontown yeah
garden stuff you're you're a third or
fourth generation moonshine yeah yeah
yeah all right yeah beaver thank you so
much for talking with me
yeah good luck with uh your daughter and
everything else that's going on with you
yeah
you wanna yeah it's great seeing you
again yeah thank you yes sir
yeah that dude yeah yeah yeah
and lovely pictures i sure do i kept up
that book
yeah you look great there those are
awesome
i've got a copy of that box and i sell
them too and it wasn't 25 to 50
feet you catch these yeah just coming up
here
hitting the counter and getting a lot of
them